pour soi bonsoir à tous bords soir jim
harrison vous publiez ou en tout cas vos
textes sont publiés en français chez
christian bourgois entre chien et loup
c'est un recueil de textes qui parlent
aussi bien de littérature que de cuisine
que des états unis évidemment par quoi
voulez-vous qu'on commence plutôt la
littérature ou plutôt la cuisine coquet
la cuisine jack nicholson votre ami vous
aviez un jour à l'issue d'un repas
pantagruélique que vous lui aviez offert
il n'y a vraiment que dans le mille de
l'ouest comprend encore pour un acte
d'héroïsme le fait de se goinfrer
c'est vrai c'est très triste
en fait mais c'est vrai un peu de
qualité ou des gorale ce temps là mais
l'ouest donc on mange trop parce qu'on
est ennuyé c'est pour ça que j'ai pris
fin peu plus les français si je ne
cuisinais pas des repas français
je poserai
220 kg comme beaucoup de mes amis
d'ailleurs vous dites un moment dans
votre livre que la cuisine minceur et
pour vous les quidams l'équivalent
morale du foxtrot
en fait c'est dégoûtant j'ai un ami qui
s'appelle tom nous avons mangé dans un
restaurant la cuisine elle ressemble
selon lui à un beau tableau il a pris le
plat est bon évidemment toute la
nourriture est tombé par terre cette
semaine j'ai mangé de la tête de veau
trois fois donc je me sens beaucoup
mieux je peux je faire comme une vache
et nous voilà
est ce que vous vous débrouillez pour
que vos livres soit traduit en france à
partir du moment où vous avez envie de
goûter je sais pas la cuisine lyonnaise
par exemple puisque vous revenez de lion
of iron will c'était merveilleux à lyon
venger ce titre deux choses longtemps
parce que pour chacun noël
machete des truffes et enfin je lui
donne l'argent et c'est elle qui
l'achète
c'est toujours une surprise j'aime bien
les cadeaux qu'on peut se sentir qu'on
peut renifler situez vous avez dit
recettes et spectaculaire vous avez
l'impression qu'il ya un rapport intime
entre le plaisir que vous avez à
cuisiner et l'acte d'écriture
est-ce que vous avez un moment dans
votre livre vous dites en écrivant comme
en faisant la cuisine on se plante si on
n'aime pas ce qu'on fait ouah ouah bon
bin hamman je devais dans les menaces et
la tradition la plus importante c'est le
tmz aux cuisiniers h/f moi faire de la
cuisine c'est la pratique de la ville
elle même
beaucoup de gens oublient qu'il faut
manger trois fois par jour de toute
façon donc que ça vaut mieux de manger
bien sinon on perd son esprit grâce j'ai
commencé aussi à faire de la cuisine
pour ne plus pratiquer l'adultère voyez
bien ce que je veux dire non non si
court après l'egypte
ça ne permet pas décrire mais si on fait
de la cuisine on est chez soi et c'est
plus pacifique
c'est vrai on ne dépense pas les
millions de dollars
pour les 10 ans et on peut utiliser cet
argent pour le vin et les truffes le
donc c'est plus équilibré et c'est très
beau ralala oui oui j'ai oublié cette
partie là c'est immoral
je suis très moral et je suis très
religieux aussi vous dit l'essentiel est
de considérer la vie comme une danse et
vous dites de la danse qu'elle est avec
la rivière la meilleure métaphore de la
vie
est-ce que d'abord il n'y a pas une
petite contradiction entre cet amour
immodéré de la cuisine et la danse parce
que ça change tous les jours j'essaie de
ne pas manger la même chose pendant une
année
sauf si je suis là je suis obligé de
manger la tête de veau deux ou trois
fois
est-ce qu'on peut pas comparer la tête
de cette vie est comme une rivière dans
ce bon c'est quelque chose qu'on ne peut
pas arrêter si on arrête on meurt c'est
dans ce sens là et qu'on arrête on
commence à se compromettre
est ce que je veux dire on commence à
penser de soi même et les romances et ne
doivent pas avoir de la personnalité
les romanciers se sont allés voir pour
tout le monde qui s'exprime au nom
le tout le monde mais si on n'arrête
d'être une rivière on commence à se
poser des questions est-ce qu'on va
malmener quand j'étais enfant maintenant
chez adultes donc on devient victime
quand on s'arrête on commence à lire ses
propres oeuvres
c'est vraiment pas la peine vous de
continuer à danser une demi-heure par
jour le reggae chez vous une nouvel
actionnaire à 6h à l'effort je faisais
les brésiliens cap vert et les faits oui
mais elle chante en portugais de toute
façon elle est extraordinaire dans sa
foi on entend des revenants ses rangs
plus rien ou parfois je me promets la
nuit dans la forêt pour me faire peur au
début vous étiez poète
vous avez même été beaucoup influencé
par une forme de poésie arabe qui
s'appelle le ghazal est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer ce que c'était et
pourquoi avoir abandonné la poésie pour
le roman je n'ai pas en fait abandonner
la paix
j'écris actuellement un long poème sur
le mexique
albane à broadway je vis une frontière
veille vers la frontière mexicaine je ne
comprends l'espagnol mais j'aime sorte
quand même quelque chose du mexique
parce que là il trouver ou à côté de
toute façon les ailes de quelqu'un qui
écrivait en france et l'angola
vous connaissez sans doute l afrique du
nord et au sierra libre un high tech a à
mon préféré quand j'avais 20 ans c'était
apollinaire parce qu'il m'a vraiment
libéré et lui il mentionnait aussi à
reculer
c'est une forme irrationnelles comme la
vie on peut sauver la nouvelle sauter
partout
il yad'abord rhinocéros et ensuite le
dîner l'un crée ensuite il ya une femme
ne nous demandent ensuite sur la lune
c'est ce type de choses comme la vie en
fait le roman c'est une forme élargie de
poésie ou c'est vous vous le vivez comme
une rupture avec le travail politique
comme un genre particulier c'est un
autre genre oui mais c'est comme si on
faisait de la course en voiture et on
change de vitesse et selon la vitesse
emmenés vers telle chose aux autres
choses simples ça peut être aussi les
rêves qui vous emmène soit vers la
poésie soit vers les romans est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment que habitait au
middle west est au coeur du continent
nord américain
c'est une position géographique qui
détermine votre point de vue de
romancier homme absolument parce que
haïti
je pense que l âme et les rêves
dépendent énormément du paysage
c'est ça l'idée à la terre ne nous
appartient pas nous appartenons à la
terre c'est le contraire est ce que nous
devenons des revendeurs de cette terre
qui nous entoure on travaille donc si
vous êtes dans l'ouest est né vous rêvez
d'un tiers je vais d'animaux en france
là je pense que j'ai rêvé une fois de
chevaliers du moyen âge et donc pour moi
les rêves émergent de la terre d'une
façon aussi naturel que les animaux est
ce que vous comprenez pourquoi les
femmes qui peuplent vos rêves se
métamorphose en oiseaux ah non non non
je pense j'ai lu quand j'avais 10 ans le
marché
beh là on en a parlé à l'aval des
coucous msa de la veille de votre vie
est un mystère et si on explique que ce
mystère on se retrouve en prise avec
tout le monde mais on est devenu artiste
pour sortir de la prison pour faire un
trou et s'en sortir
vous êtes sensible aux critiques qui
peuvent accueillir vos livres pas
tellement le jeu en ligne n'est pas lui
le new york times depuis 20 ans donc je
sais pas je préfère lire les bd vous
connaissez
une française la héroïne française bd bd
c'est plus intéressant que le new york
times
je vous posais cette question parce
qu'il ya dans votre livre une
description de l'activité critiques que
j'ai trouvé délicieuse vous dites qu'une
mauvaise critique c'est un peu comme si
quelqu'un disait que votre gamin et
l'est parfois votre gamin est vraiment
laid mais tout de même quelle genre de
boulot et cela qui consiste à dire aux
gens que leurs gamins sont laids merci
j'avais un enfant avec une énorme tâche
sur tout le visage
on verrait là la faille seulement dans
le cerveau de cette enfant on aimerait
quand même j'ai d'ailleurs je me bagarre
plus avec les critiques que je les
ignore tout simplement
il vous dit que quand vous prenez un
avion pour un long courrier par exemple
celui qui vous mène de des états unis en
france quand vous venez
si vous avez le malheur de dire à votre
voisin qui vous demande qu'est ce que
vous faites dans la vie et que vous
répondez shui poète vous avez une
conversation absolument terrifiante avec
lui et aussi terrifiante que si vous
aviez répondu je suis psychiatre
s'ils savent à que vous avez qui ne vous
est pas dangereux et il commence à
raconter leur vie parce que pour eux ma
bat c
et ce quel magicien mebara najimy
j'écris de la poésie quand j'étais jeune
quand j'avais toujours ma femme
après j'ai dû arrêter la connerie parce
que je gagne des millions de dollars je
suis très puissant c'est ce qu'ils
disent c'est ce qu'ils racontent dans
l'avion il raconte tout ce qui est
romantique dans leur pays c'est amusant
en fait c'est très drôle
le recueil de textes s'appelle donc
entre chien et loup c'est paru chez
bourgois
on compte